the next thing i remember
i always been over um
backwards
on the bar meaning my chest was up
i was staring at the blue lights and
my
chest
on this
my back was on the
countertops
and i
thought he was punching me
i felt this pressure i felt this
pressure
he oh my pubic bone
he thought he was then he was punching
me
i just saw his arm i could feel his arm
moving and i
it looked like he was
punching me
but i could just feel this pressure
it was like
hitting it
didn't feel pain it was just a pressure
on my
pubic bone and
i
don't know
i
i
i don't
remember
what i said
i just remember being really still
not wanting to move
i remember looking around the room
i remember
looking at all the broken bottles
broken glass
and i remember her that is just
not wanting to move
because i didn't know if it was broken i
didn't know if the bottle
that he had inside me was broken
i couldn't feel it i couldn't feel it i
didn't feel pain
did you communicate to mr deb what you
had drafted in the email and don't
you don't get to say what you said yes
okay
and
what if any response did mr depp have
to your sending
that email to him
he
yeah he came to new york
to
fight for the relationship for me
to prove that he was sober and he was
committed to changing
i believed he was
embarrassed and sorry he said he was and
i believed him
so i took him back or i
got back with him
on the condition that he would
uphold his promise
to do the treatment to do the full detox
clean up and never go back we got an
argument in the hotel room
and i
um i said i don't remember what i said
to him but i
said something snotty to to to him to
that provoked him it provoked him um
and when i walked
into the hallway
he grabbed me by the arm and slammed me
up against the
hallway wall and i kind of struggled
with him tried to push him off of me and
i managed to get out of his grasp
enough to
take a few steps and kind of i kind of
curved around and went into the closet
and
by the time i made it into the closet he
had me by the hair and
um
what felt like he was just wailing on me
but in a really sloppy way like hitting
the back of my head and
kind of
wrestled me down to the floor i i mean
it felt to me like i didn't even have a
fair shot because i wasn't even really i
wasn't facing him or looking at him i
was walking away from him
or else
you know i i would have at this point
even like had it
i would have tried to
defend myself more but i i didn't i kind
of felt like it didn't see it coming and
he just wrestled me down to the ground
and i remember
he was screaming at me
i mean like really screaming loud
[Music]
and
what i remember of that is trying to get
up and him kind of wrestling me back
down and at one point
put his knee on my back
it was kind of like kneeling on my back
and i just had this like
struggle with him
and i look at him and he's still got his
glasses on
i just remember looking at him and
thinking that was so
he just looked like he hadn't been
through anything you know he still had
his glasses on sunglasses
and he was screaming at me that he hated
me
that it was over
he didn't want to marry me
he was disgusted it's disgusting
he made this mistake it was a big
mistake and everyone hated me
and
i remember crying
on the floor
just
more than anything i was heartbroken i
thought maybe
he was serious i thought maybe god he
doesn't love me maybe
it's maybe he really feels this
this way
my heart
broke my heart i wanted to marry him so
bad i wanted
this is the man i loved you know
he
wrestles me
drags me up to the bed and throws me
down onto the bed and kind of wrestles
me down
onto the bed
and
he
kneels on my
back with one
one leg
and i was trying to fight him off me
because i was face down
on the bed top and
he wrestled me
down kind of trying to
hold me
down with his knee on my back
and
he's punching me
punching me with a close fist punching
me
repeatedly and i i don't remember even
feeling the pain
i just remember the sound of johnny's
voice
he got next to my ear and he was
screaming over and over and over again
each time it sounded louder and more
desperate
i [ __ ] hate you i [ __ ] hate you i
[ __ ] hate you
over and over [ __ ] hate you
and then
pounding the back of my head pounding it
with this fist and i
don't even remember
feeling pain i just
could hear
myself scream until i
couldn't hear myself anymore
i could just hear him say that he was
going to kill me
and that he sounded like an animal in
pain when he was saying he was
that he [ __ ] hated me
he sounded like he was almost crying or
something in his voice was different he
sounded different like
he sounded like he was in agony
it was high-pitched and loud
and i don't know how many times he just
hit me over and over and over again and
i got really still
and it
felt in my body like quiet
and
i thought this is how i die
you